hey while we're going through this rough
time together I thought I'd give you
some tips on how to be a good neighbor
and now it's time for Conan's good
neighbor tips
today's tip you can make cloth masks at
home the CDC recommends wearing cloth
masks in public settings to slow the
spread of the corona virus I'm gonna
zoom with my neighbors to show them how
hey neighbors check it out this is a
simple cloth mask I made it home you see
you can use any cotton cloth like an old
t-shirt you don't wear anymore
were you all able to find a t-shirt you
want to get rid of yeah this one was
sitting in the back of my closet hey
wait a minute I gave you that shirt what
about you Chris
oh I guess you probably have dozens more
of those in your closet huh nope come on
Cathy here's mine
Cathy show me the whole shirt oh man not
you too Ronnie
way I never give up my favorite Pullman
t-shirt thanks Ronnie it's my favorite
dust rag Wow
I really have some special neighbors
thanks for being a good neighbor Conan
sort of State Farm wants to thank you
and all the good neighbors out there who
are helping each other get through these
times hey did you get that State Farm
t-shirt I sent you I sure did
check it out this has been Conan's good
neighbor tips